uh GG Jackson off of his big night 23
points has the headset on court side
there at FedEx forum uh GG look I'm I'm
just going to presume that when you got
to the when you got to the Arena
tonight the last thing on your mind I'm
thinking the last thing on your mind
when you got to the Arena tonight was
you know what at the end of this game
I'm probably going to be talking to
Charles Barkley and Shaquille O'Neal and
Candace Parker uh but you are that was
not the first thing that was not the
first thing this is a dream come true
it's an honor to get to talk to all of
y'all and uh you know it's an honor to
be a part of this franchise and get to
play against Great teams yeah you just I
mean you've just turned 19 years old man
um first year out of South Carolina tell
me what it's like when you've been
playing g-league games to be in this
Arena on MLK Day against the team that
won the championship has Steph Curry two
years
ago uh you know playing with the G Le
you got to to take every game seriously
uh you know I try to play every game
just like it's an NBA game cuz that's
the ultimate goal to want to stay on
this floor and you know all glory be to
God you know I've been staying down
putting the work in uh listening to
everything the coach is telling me to do
and uh just trying to be as coachable as
possible GG sha here I don't have any
questions I just want to say
congratulations Young fella you played a
hell of a game and people didn't know
who you were they know who you are now
I'm so proud of you congratulations on
being ready brother sir it's honor to
get to hear your voice appreciate you
thank you well GJ you could tell it was
Shaq he he was mumbling
um but let me ask you a question behind
the ask how many rings you got GG I got
got GG when you are not getting to play
yeah who's working with you behind the
scenes because a lot of young guys when
they when their numbers called they're
not ready Who Behind the Scenes who has
been working with you after practice
before practice
practice um Alex Carter uh great great
shooting coach I've never been able to
shoot the ball like this in my life and
uh you know the whole g-league uh
coaching staff as well they've been a a
great support to me and uh just like I
said before you got to take every rep
seriously whether it's you know G league
practice or you know as it I got my
opportunity tonight so I had to take
this seriously as
well GG um you know obviously you were
probably at home last year watching the
NBA uh dreaming to be on the stage uh
growing up who was a player that you
modeled your game
after um it's kind of a mixture you know
a little bit of Kevin Durant Lil LeBron
uh my first pair of basketball shorts
had a 23 on it and Michael Jordan for a
long period of time was the only
basketall player uh basketball player
who I know knew so I tried to just take
different aspects of everybody game and
just mold them into
one GG Jackson has played eight games in
the NBA he had a career-high 20 the
other night a career-high 23 tonight and
I I don't know when I've Eno enjoyed a
postgame interview as much as this one
with you GG we're really happy for you
brother nice going thank you so much
appreciate you keep going young fella
keep a 20 about to get that Max contract
my boy willing I gota get my money
crib
great GG Jackson you know the moment
that was priceless is when he heard in
his headset this is this is Shaq the
look on his face uh cuz he's talking to
a real legend there only two
legends it was a never had to introduce
yourself people get tell about it
mumbling and this Ernie and me it's
three Legends here beautiful moment it
it was such it was such a 19yearold
right moment GG sha here I don't have
any questions I just want to say
congratulations young fellow you played
a hell of a game and people didn't know
who you were they know who you are now
so proud of you congratulations on being
ready
brother I just absolutely love that man
is that not
classic